when you put on a hat
it gives you height
and it gives you power
for us church hats are not just hats
they are crowns and when a woman puts
one on she becomes a queen
[Music]
my name is ivetta petty i'm kathy
anderson and i am one chambers
we've been making hats for more than 20
years
a church hat is a very special hat
especially
in the african-american community as a
child growing up in the south in the 60s
we always wore hatch sunday is the one
day historically that we had a chance
and we step out in our sunday best
i don't believe that church hats are a
thing of the past
[Music]
i have noticed that the younger
generation is taking on the tradition of
wearing hats it makes me happy to see a
younger woman with a hat on her head
because i know that she's still carrying
on the tradition
i come from a long line of church had
wearing women everyone wore hat it was a
parade it was
colors it was magic
when you go to church and and you step
in and you see all of your sisters with
hats on
we all be eyeing each other and under
our breathing boy that's a really
gorgeous hat so it it's it's wonderful
to be in a room filled with women with
hats on and each one of us look
absolutely amazing in our own right
[Music]
you